hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and Alyssa be
crazy and we're gonna watch the trailer
for a film called predestination the
International trailer it stars ethan
hawke the bird cool
I hear it's the same director of
Daybreakers that's a vampire oh I really
liked it a lot you know I thought
forever they were gonna do a sequel I've
wanted there to be a sequel and there
was no sequel I'm sorry
can I kiss you to make you feel more
comfortable about this ordeal no I heard
Ruby deals like time travel and stuff
and I like a good time travel movie Back
to the Future x-men Days of Future past
the original time machine
not the one with guy Pierce although
that one was probably the best out of
all the movies I listed what if I could
put him in front of you the man that
ruined your life if I could guarantee
that you'd get away with it
would you kill her
many New Yorkers are leaving the city
and fear of a fifth attack by the fizzle
bomber babies during the city a favor
that kind of talking getting in trouble
the worst had not already been a true
something this job has taught me is that
truth is stranger than fiction you're a
dog of a bartending or you follow me
right in here here we go that's
impossible I'm a temporal agent we
prevent crime before it takes place the
fizzle bomber his next explosion whoa
the 11,000 in do this you have skills
you've never had the chance to use and I
can give you that chance I get to be a
temporal agent if you prove yourself do
I have a choice you always have a choice
something was different about me you're
a gift given to the world to a
predestination paradox you're the only
one
you must complete your mission you must
lay the seeds for the future here you
are at the beginning to fear new life
and know where I come from where to all
you zombies come from
you hear to create history and influence
wise to come that catches up with a
fella the path you're on will take you
to your destination that looks really
cool
I love how dark it was it kind of
reminds me a little bit of Inception but
with time travel instead I know dude I'm
on this channel I know I love you but
first you won't suck my dick you don't
let me kiss you and now you haven't seen
inception you know this means I should
rent it all the way over here this felt
like honestly I love that it's like
super dark it's I feel like it'll play
with your brain yeah I know I like it
good kind of thinker I like a good
science fiction movie where it is
something where you're like it's
impossible to do that you know if this
was real would it really work like I
like I like movies that are thought out
in a very fictitious world and Ethan
Hawke was cooling it to you yeah like
it's like little mustache thing that's
what really stronger than all the things
you could have said about me chose
mustache mustache she's got a cool
mustache you don't ever see Ethan Hawke
really rock on mustache that's true and
he's worked with this director before
this kind of reminds me of like blooper
and inception oh this has a loop
reception to it inset to bird I'm gonna
be that person you guys just for a
second because it needs to be said with
things like movies like this time-travel
you know they go back in time to prevent
future crimes if they prevent it before
it happens why does it happen in the
future for them to go back and prevent
you don't have to do this don't do this
I know I know I know I used I have to be
the person that like I know but in it in
order for the thing to happen they're
showing that part in time that took
place to go there yes what it doesn't it
shouldn't exist but it's showing that at
first it did exist and now we're
watching it through a person's
perspective of changing time we're not
watching just time
yeah but okay like if they go back and
kill somebody before they do something
stupid its conversations over ELISA I
I'm sorry baby come here you know will
happen with that conversation we'll just
keep going in circles forever but it's
not gonna it's not gonna a be something
where any of us understand each other we
might lose a friendship over it
I would cut you out of my life if we
didn't agree by the end that simple I
would instantly forgive you thank you
good we get each other
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe right here that would
be really cool if you want to do that
and ELISA has her own YouTube channel -
it's called ELISA be crazy and be crazy
and what's most important you get to see
more of those bad boys in her videos
that's right show some cleavage oh yeah
sorry zero I'm okay yes boobs well these
two kind of follow me wherever I go I
don't really have a choice they're kind
of like those hitchhikers that never
leave yeah so you should subscribe yeah
when a man loves a woman he really wants
a touch of boob all right next we're
gonna shot us some people I already did
koopa troopa poopa and you give me a
shout-out please you guys are amazing
keep up the awesome work well Koopa
Troopa poopa that's Italian sausage
you're really nice nice dude dude I love
Koopa man Koopas cool he's really cool
you could be the next coop you could be
King Koopa yeah you could uh you could
poop - yeah it's true you never think
about characters that need to poop
pooping is one of the most important
things in life it's essential and it's
cool that Koopa Troopa knows that he has
to be a pooper okay unhealthy things can
happen if you don't go food get rid of
toxic waste building up in your colon
Jesus I don't think I want to know I
could teach you about it it's why it's
important to take probiotics fiber you
know right digestive enzymes with my
body you can see I clearly apply all
this knowledge and I'm a Koopa Troopa
thanks for reminding the people that you
got to be a poopoo Hamina eat oh hey
Ryan can I get a shout-out
look at me my evil of course you can - I
thought that is a Japanese fan you and
that is what I've done that is not a
specific race it's uniquely right you
are beautiful you are beautiful anyway
hi danette oh yeah you can have a
shout-out dude
well what what is your Hemi 92 what it
would it I said Heidi Hemi honey - what
what what ethnicity is that what
ethnicity is that my friend are you
Japanese Italian that'd be cool Japanese
Italian oh wow nice tongue imagine what
else you could do with that time is that
why yeah well I could you know wet your
lips for you if you want no it's not
gonna happen is it
always since day one what did I tell you
when I first met you I'm Italian no I
didn't like say hey you're Italian
I didn't compliment you no you looked at
me you're like pure Italian
like my bad
no Yuto you haven't even much to work
with your buddy you just asked for a
shout-out you know like do you want me
to do something specific do you want me
to like say your name and avoid I can do
voices I can do voices Alyssa what a
play should end it Batman
okay I mean I eat oh you deserve a share
we must be friends because in Batman he
goes he must have friends Batman day
hello we need to do Batman stuff my
hammy was a pooper kuba videos done
this is stupid stupid awesome you're
never stupid don't ever call yourself
stupid it's bringing yourself down think
positive things need to be positive
things go right you're like oh you won't
have sex with me so I'm going sex with
Joker right now it's gonna be exactly
what I will be jealous fine I'm just
whatever you know I end up
why are you still here